hi I'm Hannah and I'm addicted to
Christmas sweaters my sweater collection
started probably six years ago I bought
a sweater vest on eBay and it smelled
horrible but it was just the funniest
thing in the world and it snowballed
into this long-running joke of just
buying any vintage Christmas sweater I
get my hands on my mom joined in and
together we have a collection of upwards
of 350 I know I'm crazy I'll be the
first one to say I'm totally insane
this is a good crazy it's it's fun I
wear one every day of the month of
December and it makes people happy I
walk down the street and before like
that's a cool sweater the sweaters are
so cool if you spent the time to just
look through each one and see how funny
and cool they are I think it's awesome
my idol the only person I'd like to meet
if I could meet anyone in the world it
would be Michael Simon he does the most
brilliant designs the most in your face
disgusting Christmas barf all over
everything wherever you go on a Michael
Symon sweater like people know that
you're there because they can sense the
Christmas coming off your sweater if I
had to guess how much money we've spent
on Christmas sweaters it's probably
about $2,000 we have a few sweaters that
are going for about $500 now the
character ones are insanely popular so I
think we could probably triple what we
spent if we sold all of them but now
we're going to attach so I think we're
gonna keep them all it's impossible to
make an ugly Christmas sweater like the
way you'd make it is how do I make a
really nice Christmas sweater and that's
what these are when you see the ones now
that are trying to be ugly you can tell
the difference it's not authentic it's
not an actual Christmas sweater with the
intent of looking really glamorous I
like that this is a thing that's brought
my mom and I really close literally the
only reason we have it is because it
makes people happy so that's probably my
favorite part about owning all chase the
mailman really really hated my mom for a
while because he'd come with just this
giant bin full of packages because we'd
have like fit
water's coming at a time on the Reg